un inédito paso hacia la reparación
ocaña un municipio en el noreste de
colombia fue el escenario de una
audiencia en la que diez militares
retirados confesaron las ejecuciones de
más de un centenar de civiles entre 2007
y 2008 haciéndolos pasar como
guerrilleros unas confesiones detalladas
que se hicieron frente a los familiares
de las víctimas le arrebate la ilusión a
sus hijos
de desgarra el corazón a sus madres
por una presión por unos resultados por
unos falsos resultados el acto se
enmarca en la labor de la jurisdicción
especial para la paz el mecanismo de
justicia transicional que surgió de los
acuerdos de paz entre el gobierno de
colombia entonces en cabeza del ex
presidente juan manuel santos y la
extinta guerrilla de las farc y que
busca esclarecer los crímenes cometidos
en el marco del conflicto armado
colombiano entre ellos los 'falsos
positivos'
según el organismo seis mil
cuatrocientos dos civiles fueron
ejecutados y presentados por el ejército
como bajas de combate entre 2002 y 2008
bajo el gobierno del expresidente álvaro
uribe vélez unos asesinatos por los que
recibieron bonos permisos ascensos y
medallas asesinaron
sistemáticamente a civiles para
presentarlos como falsas bajas en
combate y así engrosar sus resultados
operacionales los familiares de las
víctimas tuvieron la oportunidad de
hacer algunas de las preguntas que los
han acompañado durante años para ustedes
valía más un premio unas vacaciones unas
comisiones unas condecoraciones
que el dolor de una madre una verdad
completa detallada y exhaustiva y un
reconocimiento de la responsabilidad que
persigue la reparación de las víctimas
son los criterios que establece la gp
para que los victimarios puedan obtener
sanciones alternativas a un tiempo en
prisión